what do you teach your clients about
money
oh man what don't i teach about no
money is such an important topic i think
on and really anyone's journey not even
specific to hollywood
i am still in my own
learning journey you know of
wealth consciousness and working on my
money mindset
but what i like to teach them is
really focus on what is possible and
what sounds exciting instead of focusing
on
what doesn't feel good so for example
this this uh example comes up a lot
because
i remember my clients telling me about
this other teacher
teaching about this when you
are focusing on your writer director
actor and you're focusing on
this is how much of my paycheck goes to
taxes and this is how much of my
paycheck goes to
my agent or manager and i am left with
so
little when you are focusing on i am
left with so
little you are going to create more of
that
in your life in your career right
whatever we focus on expands
so instead of going oh my gosh if i book
a
co-star and i only make 800 for the day
and then i guess i start with the
thousands easier math to do in my head
you know i only make a thousand dollars
for the day
and you know uh 30 of that is going to
taxes
20 is going to my agent and manager and
i'm only going home with like 500 bucks
that really sucks
to me that is the most people thinking
right so in terms of money
instead of focusing on
how much it sucks when you're left with
little money at the end of the day
instead what if you focus on what if i
booked a recurring role for twenty
thousand dollars
and then even though some of it's going
to taxes and my agent and manager
i'm still left with a pretty nice chunk
of change right so
instead of focusing on limitations and
what
you know feels like your fate is going
to be and really focus on
um you know the the downside of all of
that
focus on what's possible focus on being
the one
that gets 10 million dollar paychecks
from a movie
you know again it's like the most people
pool and the high achiever pool
that high achiever pool people who are
making 10 million dollars a movie might
be smaller than
most people in the industry but let's
focus on that because that's how you get
there
you know so it's so important to really
think from an abundant mindset about
what is possible how do you teach people
to stretch that
i guess it's a muscle i get kind of like
what i was telling you with
you know my success is inevitable in
addition to
suggesting lots of books and resources
that i love
that i think are really helpful um
because i think that it's
money mindset is is a deep conversation
that needs to happen over time
we need to unlearn a lot of things and
relearn new things and
take a look at our own um money patterns
but
just like with my success inevitable
it's like let's start looking for proof
okay i had a client that booked a 17 000
job right so there's proof
that somebody i worked with you know in
the
recent you know past or whatever um
booked a bigger paycheck was able to
receive a bigger paycheck
so now your subconscious goes oh
so it's possible oh so it's possible for
me to get that
right so again it's like feeding your
subconscious mind proof
of what's possible because proof exists
we just choose not to focus on it we
choose to focus on the people that are
coming home with 500 and feeling broke
but instead
all this other evidence also exists
we're just saying that it's so rare
and that that's not possible for us or
it's like winning the lottery right
and so it's really about looking for
that proof and going okay
that is what i want to focus on and that
is what i'm working towards
the gilmore girls example that you gave
again she had been modeling but she'd
never had a speaking role
no wow and how long was i i mean this
show is doesn't it
like seven seasons and then they
recently did the
you know netflix special that was four
episodes long
yeah but there's great like you know i i
love the show so i've watched interviews
and things like that behind the scenes
and i read lauren graham's one of her
books
and lauren graham talks about how she
played uh
alexis bledel's mother as the two of
them for people that don't know gilmore
girls
lauren graham talks about she's like if
you ever see a scene where i'm like
grabbing alexis's arm and pulling her
close to me
she's like i was pulling her on her mark
because
she was so new that she you know she
didn't in the beginning you know
she didn't necessarily know all those
things like oh you need to stand on your
mark and you know things that
a seasoned actor would know and so even
without all that that's how new she was
even without all that knowledge
and all that experience she's still
booked the title one of the
title roles series regular like seven
seasons
wow see and that's
possible when we focus on that instead
of you know
the actor who books one co-star a year
and really struggles right it's like
both evidence exists which one do we
want to focus on
how does money change an artist i don't
think money changes anybody
i think again it's it's all internal
so whatever it looks like money changed
was already there inside right so
sometimes they say you know
fame is like holding up a magnifying
glass to what's already there
you know like for example i worked on a
show i won't mention names but i worked
on a show where one of the lead
actresses
was not a very nice person and
i found out that people who knew her
before she was famous
said that she was like that then you
know she wasn't a nice person that
it's like it's like holding up a
magnifying glass so i don't just think
that
money i don't think any external thing
changes us
you know i think that only you know i
mean events and things like that i guess
can shift our perception or
our feelings our beliefs but i don't
think like a tangible thing like
money which is just like a value
exchange i don't think that necessarily
changes people i think again it's like a
magnifying glass to what's already there
so a lot of times people will feel
when i have x amount of money all my
money problems will go away
but having more money doesn't change
your spending habits
it doesn't change your saving habits or
what you do with your money how you
treat your money
you are the person that does that it
might inspire you to change
your habits you know it might inspire
you to do things differently
but i don't think money actually changes
people
from the people you've worked with how
does their
outward success change the people around
them oh
good question i
cuz i love that like to me that it makes
me so happy to help
i say spread the light like i want to
spread the light in hollywood you know
the people that i work with
helping them feel good and feel inspired
again will then help people around them
feel inspired
so again i think it's more about the
internal
changes than the external things that
they book the projects that they book
um i think that you know like um one of
my clients was saying
that her mom said oh you know you're
you're so upbeat
recently you know you're so positive and
happy and she was like yes
you know i'm a month working with erica
um so i think that it's more the
internal shift
that impacts people around them in a
positive way but
you know i guess the things that they
the projects that they might book or the
external things
um can kind of i guess with the internal
shifts also
help impact people but you know what i'm
seeing and what i
and what i really hope is that it
impacts people for the better where it
inspires other people to go after their
dreams
and it shows other people what's
possible you know
when i first started out 13 almost 13
years ago
i read jack canfield's success
principles
it's my very first self-help book i ever
read and i was like this is the greatest
thing ever
i loved it so much and i think it really
helped me break in
to hollywood so quickly and one of the
tactics that he talked about was writing
your goals on an index card
and so i would do that for every goal
for years i don't do it anymore
um because my my belief around that has
shifted a little bit but like
my dad started writing his goals down
on index cards i was like that is so
cool
you know i think you know there's
something so incredible about inspiring
others to go after their dreams or to
believe
in more you know believe in more
possibility for themselves by seeing
people they know or love do it but what
if that doesn't happen
what if it doesn't inspire others what
if it takes another turn
what do you mean what if somehow um
they can't handle that have you seen
that in like the person who
who's succeeding or the person that's
watching them the person that's
succeeding what if
some of the individuals around them that
threatens them
have you worked with your clients on
that and and how do they internalize
that
so they're feeling threatened by their
success or the dynamics changed
power structures changed and so it
upsets the apple cart
yeah i mean that absolutely does happen
and i've coached many clients through
that i think especially with friends
um and i think that
you know you can't control somebody
else's journey
right so so like my client can't control
their friend getting on board and being
excited and being inspired or feeling
threatened or
feeling you know not good about it or
whatever right
we can't control somebody else's journey
they're on their own path and so
it's not up to us how they feel
and and one of the things that i work
with my clients a lot is because a lot
of times when we're doing
the mindset it's really the internal
shifts that
that impact their relationships the most
and and a lot of times
i say that when you start changing and
growing
what you used to tolerate becomes less
tolerable
so the people that maybe aren't getting
on board
maybe were never meant to get on board
with them right and maybe it was
something they were tolerating before
but it's like they can't even tolerate
anymore they don't want to be around
them
right so i think that you know it's
important that we surround ourselves
with people who support
us and who want us to win and are you
know and excited for us
and if people are feeling you know
negative nancy's they're feeling down
um that's okay you know they're on their
own path
but the more we surround ourselves with
people like that the more time we spend
with them
the more it can start to drag us down if
we're not
incredibly strong about our own energy
and thought process
so i i never think it's about like oh
you need to break up with this friend
you know i don't think it's necessarily
about cutting people out of your life
but
just being more um present and and
aware of the kinds of conversations you
have with them
and and the things that they say and
then how it impacts
how you feel when you've had a client
reach tremendous success
what were some of the surprises that
they weren't ready to handle
well i work with i've worked with a lot
of new
people so tremendous success i i don't
know if
you know that's that's all relative and
i don't know if i've like i don't know
if i've ever coached somebody that
that achieved something so incredible
that they weren't ready for because i
think
that the work that we do gets them ready
for it
um and that's always what it's about
like it's all again it's always the
internal
thing you know how do you feel about
what is happening
and do you have support around you you
know that's like why some of my clients
end up staying into
like i have a membership where it's just
a couple coaching calls a month in a
group setting
so that they can keep up with the you
know the work to keep up with that
belief system keep up with that mindset
work so that as they do
achieve things they have the support
system to
to help them you know handle anything
that comes their way
so so some of this has never come as a
surprise to them
it it's they they've taken these steps
and they were ready
emotionally yeah nothing's ever a
surprise i mean
like because i train them to expect
success and i don't even i shouldn't
even say i train them
i don't want to take responsibility they
they shift their belief system
to believe that their success is coming
so
nothing it's never a surprise it's
exciting and they're really happy about
it and you know it's funny
like even small things one of my clients
um texted me the other day in our in her
session
she she moved home during the pandemic
and is going to move back to l.a soon
and she was like
you know when do i move like i'm looking
at places i don't know when the timing
is right and i said
well when you find a place that you love
that feels really good
and i was like watch i bet this week
you'll find a place now that we have
this conversation
and she texted me the next day and was
like you won't believe one of those
departments just became available that i
was interested in
so there's never it's never a surprise
it's expected i mean it's
it's surprised in the way of like wow
this really did come true this really
did happen and there's excitement around
that but
never a surprise so expect
success okay i like that and do you
think with the every
people pool it's not expected
correct i'm hoping yeah correct i'm
fingers crossed okay ask anyone
ask ask most people you know ask them
what they
believe about about their success and or
about the next booking or the next job
or whatever and
yeah most people do not expect it
they expect failure or they expect it to
take a long time or they expect struggle
you